good morning George Wednesday I'm really
really late in fact right now it is 11
54 which means that I have 6 minutes to
get my video to languages why I'm using
quick capture right now because the only
way that I can get back with you online
in time to not get a second punishment
and have to do two punishments at once
because I really don't wanna do anything
embarrassing while I'm dressed like
Carrie Bradshaw because that's
embarrassing our bond zone
thank you very much so I have to do this
in one take Kathryn and I are going to
be after this is done after as a special
addendum because obviously this isn't
the best Brotherhood 2.0 video that ever
have in the world because Kathryn and I
are really late because we had to go see
Nick and Norah's Infinite Playlist
because I completely forgot that I had
to post video and so we were doing that
I'm sorry about that
so after this because this isn't the
best Brotherhood 2.0 video in the world
we will be performing a very special
song as part of song Wednesday in the
tradition even though it will
technically in the East Coast be
Thursday anyway doesn't matter it's
going to be awesome and you should stick
around if you can stay which do you ache
a little bit earlier then a little bit
later stay a little bit earlier sure
that's what I said then then you should
do that Kathryn now going to be playing
a really awesome song from dr.
Horrible's sing-along blog news
scattered and I just got back from
Seattle today it was awesome thank you
so much Charlotte everybody who were
there thank you to Molly Smith at 4:23
you should go subscribe to her right now
thank you to Kaylee and Christina of the
five awesome girls who were there it was
really really really great and really a
ton of fun and I think that we sort of
like owned that library I don't think
they had ever had a bigger crowd in that
library ever I'm not really big news
John Green is going to have his second
week on the New York Times bestseller
list at number six which is really
amazing because it's like people are
still buying jungkook it wasn't just
like initial nerdfighter spurt be like
ah you don't get paper jobs there's like
people still buying it a lot which means
that we kick butt which is very exciting
other awesome news is that Kathryn and I
watched Nick and Norah's Infinite
Playlist which is being produced by the
same production company that auction
that optioned auctioned optioned Paper
Towns so Jon may be writing a screenplay
for those very people who did Nick and
Norah's Infinite Playlist which was a
really great movie I really enjoyed it a
lot and it made me sort of teary and
want to kiss Karen a lot at the end so
that's all I have for you
today this is my first first I think
first ever 1:1 take brother 2.0 video so
you know what's special in that regard
in any case but even special or will be
a few wait around for you know maybe an
hour so Katherine and I are gonna put
together an awesome song for you guys
and it's gonna be great so you know if
you can't stay up then just go come
online in the morning and we'll be there
and if you can then I will see you that
you can wait though it's good you should
wait though it's good John I will see
you tomorrow